what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I have a
special announcement so as you guys know
we've been going through a lot of
changes the last couple months and we
came to the conclusion that we are
closing down the jpt network it's done
and over with gone nasiki NADA so we
have a new channel named The Audacity
Network and if you want to subscribe to
our new channel the audacity Network the
link to that is in the description but
we decided that I can't do this alone I
can't fight these crazy feminists these
wokies if it's just me I'm gonna I'm
gonna be all by myself crying because
I'm a woman all right so we decided
we're gonna bring on someone to the team
drum roll please welcome to the team
Christine hello
So Christine how do you feel about
joining the audacity Network great it's
definitely going to be a challenge to
women versus what seems to be the
majority of delusional women on the
planet crazy chicks we got this yeah you
you stood out because you came on the
show and she just talked since I was
like wow is there someone else that
isn't brainwashed completely so tell
them about your essay videos that you're
going to be doing yeah so I have a
series that I'm working on at the moment
uh called debunking the lunacy the gist
of it is kind of in the name uh
basically I'm looking at things in
society that I think are completely
insane and that seem to have been
normalized and trying to break it down
in an in-depth video and that obviously
has a lot of research gone into it
trying to build an argument for why
things seem wrong in today's society and
how we can perhaps make them right so
yeah if you like that kind of thing you
want to check it out definitely go see
my videos yes and guys I'm telling you
she's the best in the game when it comes
to the essay videos nobody on YouTube
it's like we got these wokies making
these essay videos trying to brainwash
the women I was like no nayski NADA we
gotta fix this but if you guys are
interested in joining the network we are
looking for two to three more talents in
London so DM me on Instagram just pearly
things one make sure you put in what
your channel would be about and maybe a
little video of you talking or something
you have to be in London please stop
dming me from all these other places
when we have locations and other places
we'll do that second announcement we are
making a location in the United States
um in the fall probably November time
frame likely Chicago but you know I've
been thinking maybe Vegas or Miami I
changed my mind every week I'm a woman
but that that is a new announcement but
welcome to the network Christine I'm
very excited to be here thank you so
much for joining us guys like the video
make sure you go subscribe we're trying
to get her monetized within a week yes
we want we want to have her apply for
monetization in a week so make sure you
go subscribe get her to a thousand
subscribers like the video and we'll
talk to you next time